I grew up Christian. My whole life was
in Christian communities at churches,
different churches, different
denominations. My whole life never even
heard of people keeping Lent until last
year. We actually did a video on this
whole topic last year where this hallow
app was being pushed, shoved down our
throats and promoted on every YouTube
channel, every uh channel on TV,
whatever. constantly this hello app with
all your favorite celebrities wearing
ashes on their foreheads trying to make
it look cool to celebrate Lent. What is
Lent? I haven't seen it in the Bible,
but here you see Mark Wahlberg and
Jonathan Roomie from The Chosen. He
plays the actor or he's the actor who
plays Jesus and The Chosen.
And here they are with ashes in the
shape of a cross on their forehead. Why
are they hanging out with this Catholic
priest who literally has the crow's
foot, the witch's foot on his robe? If
you don't know what that is, that's
where the whole peace sign comes from. A
lot of people say it's a broken cross.
Really, it dates back to this thing
called the the witch's foot or the
crow's foot. I just think that's really
interesting. But they're hanging out
with the priest because that's how you
get the ashes. You don't do the ashes
yourself. you go to a priest and the
priest puts the ashes on your forehead
in the shape of this plus sign or cross.
Um, and that's what's going on right
here. They're they're promoting this
whole concept.
So, what is Lent? It's a 40-day solemn
Christian season of fasting, prayer, and
penance.
Christians do penance. I didn't know
that. or beginning on Ash Wednesday and
ending before Easter. Observed by
Catholics, Orthodox, and many Protestant
denominations, it says it commemorates
the 40 days Jesus spent fasting in the
desert serving as a time for spiritual
preparation and renewal. Who celebrates
Lent? Primary observers, Roman,
Catholics, Eastern Orthodox, Anglicans,
Episcopalians, Lutherans, and
Methodists. Like I said, I grew up in
the non-denominational world, the
Baptist world. Never saw any Christians
around me ever with ashes on their
forehead. Never. I grew up in the '9s,
never saw it. Now suddenly, like
everybody is promoting that they're
keeping this. The Catholic Church is the
most popular and largest Christian
denomination in the world. Did you know
that? Out of all the Christian
denominations that you've heard of,
Catholicism is number one Christian
quote unquote Christian denomination.
That's frightening. When you study Bible
prophecy and you really understand who
the beast of Revelation is, the fact
that the Catholic Church, the ecumenical
church, the mother of harlots church is
the number one, that's terrifying. But
there is a push. There's a push to push
people towards the beast system, the
antirist system. Where did Catholicism
come from? It was pagan Rome who were
killing Christians in the coliseums and
Constantine was killing Christians and
for every Christian that he killed 10
more would pop up. It was it was said
that the blood of the martyrs was like
seed on the ground and for every
Christian that was killed in that
coliseum somebody in the audience was
watching and said that person has
something worth dying for and I don't
even have anything worth living for and
they converted to Christianity and
because Constantine could not kill
Christianity. It was the old saying, if
you can't beat them, join them. He said
that he saw this vision of a red cross
in the sky. And he started painting red
crosses on his soldiers shields. And it
said that he converted to Christianity,
but he really took control over it. He
said, "You can go to church, but you
must go to church on Sunday instead of
the Sabbath day. And if you're caught
keeping the seventh day, you will be
persecuted because you're Judaizing is
what he said. But if you're a Christian,
you can go to church on the venerable
day of the sun and all the shops will be
closed. And uh he also said that you can
go in these temples with all these false
gods, these statues of idols. And he
said, "No, that's not Mercury, Mars, and
Venus. That's Peter, Paul, Paul, and
John." And so this this is where
Catholicism was bred from with all these
Babylonian systems of sprinkling infant
baptism, calling a man father which
Jesus said do not call any man father
but your father in heaven confessional
all these things the nunnery all of this
stuff comes from Babylon which turned
into you know Babylon was conquered by
uh Meo Persia conquered ed by Greece and
eventually became Rome. So, Babylon just
got a new disguise over the years until
now its disguise is that it's Christian.
I hope everybody who watches this
channel knows just because something's
labeled Christian doesn't make it
Christian. You have to see, you have to
judge by its fruit. That's what Christ
said, right? You will know them by their
fruits. So, what is the fruit of
Catholicism? a lot of tradition, a lot
of man-made rituals, right? I thought it
was interesting when I came across
Whoopi Goldberg because her sexuality
has been questioned a lot and she
actually says that she's not a lesbian,
not gay, but has a lot of gay friends.
But Whoopi Goldberg was actually
attacking Christians saying, "Is this
the way Jesus wants you to be?"
And she was talking, she was standing up
for killing children in the womb and
saying that Jesus wouldn't judge people
who killed their babies in the womb.
Interesting because I do remember a
verse that says something about um those
who pass their children through the fire
of Baal will be damned that it's
abomination. But somehow Wolfie Goldberg
missed that verse. Um, I'm gonna look at
this commercial that came on during the
Super Bowl halftime show and it was all
about this Hallow app. Check this out.
God, we take this moment just to give
you [music] thanks. We thank you for
this time to come together as a family,
as friends,
and [music] as a country.
Help us, Lord, especially this Lent to
grow closer [music] to you. Amen. Join
us in prayer this Lent on Hallow. Stay
prayed up.
Stay prayed up, y'all. It looks good.
That's the way Satan works, right? Satan
is a deceiver. Deception is a lot of
truth with a little bit with a little
bit of error. So, when you hear things
like, "Yeah, we want to pray and seek
God and all these things, it all sounds
good." But when you're giving the sign
of the the cross on yourself and you're
having ashes put on your head by a
priest, where is all this coming from?
This is not the God of the Bible.
They're not talking about praying to the
God of the Bible. Even these people
might even think they are. These people
may be deceived themselves. But when you
really study Bible prophecy, you will
see that soon there is coming a one
world religion. And America, the world
dominating power right now, is going to
cause all to worship the first beast.
Revelation says that the second beast
which rose sometime after the fall of
the first beast, Rome, it can only be
America is going to cause the whole
world to worship the first beast. And
what do we see happening right now? We
actually see emerging of America and
Rome. We now have the first American
pope. And now we have commercials on the
Super Bowl pushing for Catholicism and
keeping Lent. Like I said, I never seen
Christians, Protestant Christians,
keeping Lent, but this year I saw on
CBN, which is Christian Broadcast
Network, and they were talking about
Lent bring or Lent begins today with Ash
Wednesday, what does the Bible say? I
thought that was interesting. What does
the Bible say? Because it doesn't say
anything about doing this, but um this
video seems to be promoting it. Listen
to what he says. And today, as you
already know, is Ash Wednesday. It's the
first day of the season of Lent. And
during this time, many Christians
observe fasting, prayer, and tried to
draw closer to God. Well, Lori Johnson
tells us more.
>> Millions of Christians observe Ash
Wednesday by wearing ashes on their
forehead in the shape of a cross.
>> So, in the Bible, ashes represents two
things. It it represents repentance and
our own mortality. So when you look back
in scripture when Jonah preached to
Nineveh, Nineveh, the king repented in
sackcloth and in ash. Ash Wednesday is
the first day of Lent, a season in the
Christian calendar leading up to Easter.
It's a time for Christians to examine
themselves and draw closer to God, often
through the practice of fasting. Fasting
is an extraordinary biblical practice
that will do two things for us. Firstly,
it helps us to curb our human appetites.
And the second thing that it will do, it
creates space for God. It creates
spiritual hunger so that we can run
after him.
>> Lent lasts 40 days until Palm Sunday,
the beginning of Easter week when Jesus
entered Jerusalem days before his
crucifixion and resurrection.
>> This is crazy. I never dreamed I would
be seeing Protestant television
promoting these Catholic traditions and
rituals that are nowhere found in the
Bible. But that's where we're at. We're
at a time where Christians don't even
know what's in the Bible or what's not
in the Bible. And they'll actually blend
these things together and say, "Yeah,
you know, it talks about putting ashes
on your head and all this stuff." You
know what the Bible also says? It says
when you're fasting, which is what 40
days of Lent is all about. When you're
fasting, don't let anyone else know. It
actually says wash your face, which
means you won't have ashes on your face.
Wash your face and and look healthy and
and happy and don't let other people
know by sinking your cheeks in and and
looking sickly because he said that's
what the hypocrites do. The hypocrites
are fasting outwardly for the applause
of men. But Jesus said, "Don't do that."
So, how can you have ashes on your face
and wash your face and fast? You see the
dilemma here? Not only the Super Bowl
and now Christian Broadcast Network, but
even the news is interviewing these guys
about keeping lint and using this Hello
app. On this Ash Wednesday, we wanted to
take a closer look at a popular Catholic
prayer and meditation app called Hallow.
>> As Fox Sharon Crowley tells us in
tonight's Finding Faith, the app has
some big time celebrity support
with Sharon Crowley. I think that's
really interesting. Look at those eyes.
Anyway,
oh, hey guys. Sorry, I must have
forgotten to silence my phone. I was
just praying.
>> Classic Jesus.
>> That's why we're calling Hallow. This
Lent.
>> Absolutely.
>> Sweet.
>> Pray every day this Lent on Hallow. Stay
>> prayed up.
>> High-powered Hollywood celebrities
putting their famous faces behind a
popular prayer app called Hallow.
>> Hey, Chris Pratt here. I just wanted to
invite you to take a moment and meditate
on scripture with me.
>> The idea is to really help people build
a daily habit of prayer to bring God
into every aspect of their life.
Searching for a way to better understand
his own relationship with God. Seven
years ago, Aleandro De Santo left his
finance job to help develop the Hallow
app.
>> So, this app blew up. Listen to this.
>> We are literally counting single-digit
downloads for the first few weeks and
months. Uh this past month, we just
crossed 30 million downloads across
>> 30 million downloads. Now, they're
promoting this thing hardcore. I mean,
Super Bowl at the beginning of every
YouTube channel, you got all these
celebrities endorsing it. And and where
did this come from? Catholicism. We just
saw that the very woman who was giving
Christians a hard time saying, "Is this
the way Jesus wants you to act because
she is pro-choice and pro-LGBTQ?"
And on their show, she's the main host,
The View. Um, here she is just a day ago
with ashes on her forehead.
>> Please welcome Mark Wahlberg and
Jonathan Room.
[music]
[cheering]
Does this really look like Is this what
prayer and fasting looks like? you know,
put ashes on your forehead, get on the
Super Bowl, get on the view, make
commercials, hyping it up. I I think
they've actually kind of lost sight of
what they're trying to promote here.
They're saying it's about getting closer
to Christ and fasting and and praying,
but when the Bible talks about praying
and fasting, it says pray in your closet
where nobody can see. Don't let your
left hand know what your right hand's
doing. And when you're fasting, wash
your face. Now, you tell me which is
biblical.
Where did this come from? This is not
biblical, guys. That's that's what I'm
trying to prove right here that this is
not biblical. This is being pushed onto
society, using the influencers of the
world to push people towards Babylon,
towards Rome. And then Whoopi Goldberg,
you know, she she talked about here
where she is pro-abortion. Listen. And
and she liked Pope Francis because he
didn't judge those who had abortions.
>> Yeah.
>> What do you think of the Pope's speeches
and what he's doing and saying?
>> Listen, I you know, this is the first
time
uh since probably John the 23rd that
I've been reinterested and reinvigorated
because this guy,
you know, he read the book, he gets it.
He remembers what this is all about. you
know, he's, you know, to Catholics, he's
he's the the direct connection to God.
So, if he says, "Listen,
I don't think you need to be obsessed
with gay people. I don't think that's
what we need to be thinking about. I
think we need to be thinking about how
do we make our church better? How do we
make our church more inclusive?"
>> You know, how do we say, you know, he
said, you know, quit hurting women's
feelings about having gotten an
abortion. I don't want women to get
abortions, but I understand why they do.
>> What? I don't want people I don't want
women to have abortion, but I understand
why they do. See, the the very word
Catholic means universal. The whole idea
of Catholicism is ecumenicism. And
that's not what the Bible says that
Christianity is at all. Jesus said,
"I've come not to bring peace, but to
divide." Because the truth divides. When
you say, "I am the way, the truth, and
the life, and no one comes to the father
but by me," that divides people because
there's a lot of beliefs around the
world. And the majority of them do not
believe that Jesus is the only way.
There's a form of religion and a form of
Christianity that's not true
Christianity. And in fact, it's
antichrist.
We hear that word antichrist and we
think that means you're against Christ,
but really it means in place of Christ.
So when the the world's largest
Christian denomination is Catholicism,
which says that a man is your mediator
between you and God and you call him
father, that is antichrist by
definition. And here we see all the
celebrities promoting this on their
Instagrams because when you see people
in real life, these people look, she
took a selfie of herself. That's
influential more so than seeing an an
actor on a movie, right? She's showing
you, look, remember you are dust and
dust you shall return. May this Linton
season bring you closer uh in your walk
with the Lord. Now look, man, I'm not
here to judge. I'm actually excited that
I see Christ that I see celebrities
coming to Christ, but there are things
that concern me with Melissa Joonhart. I
actually saw her on a show where she was
talking to a medium and the medium said,
"I'm going to connect you with your
grandmother." And in the beginning, she
was like, "You know, I don't I don't
know how I feel about this. You know,
the Bible says some things about talking
to the dead." And all the medium had to
say was, "Oh, no. He was talking about
pagan mediums. I'm a Christian medium.
I'm a good one. And she goes, "Oh, I'm
so glad. Let's do this." And the and
this gay Christian medium said that he
saw her grandma and gave her a message
and she's crying and her mom's backstage
crying. And this is what I'm talking
about. This is not true Christianity.
This is deception. And I and I pray that
she comes to know the truth about what
happens when you die. That you should
not talk to the dead. That it's
necromancy. But this is where she's at.
And she's promoting and pushing putting
ashes on your forehead for 40 days,
which is nowhere found in the Bible. You
won't find it in the Bible. Uh David
Henry, who was a Disney kid and the
descendants and wizards of uh WA Waverly
Place, him and his wife put in the ashes
on their foreheads saying, "Today the
church marks our foreheads." That's
interesting. Which church? Today, the
church marks our foreheads with a cross
and reminds us that everything turns to
dust except the soul except eternity
except Christ. Interesting because he's
literally telling you that when you die,
you're still alive. That your soul is
still alive somewhere. That's not what
the Bible actually teaches. The Bible
says the soul that sinnth, it shall die.
And yet he's saying no, the soul doesn't
die. Actually, um here's a a Poland
model or something and she says, "A
reminder that everything we have is a
blessing and nothing matters more than
faith, family, and a kind hearted and a
kind of heart we carry through this
world." Pushing the ash Wednesday. Um
here are some newscasters,
meteorologists, anchors, and for some
reason they all happen to be in their
car and she's proud to be Catholic. Not
proud to be a follower of Christ, proud
to be Catholic. Remember, this is a
Catholic ritual. And yet, right now,
Protestants are pushing this as well.
Here's another one. Every time I forget
I have ashes on my forehead, someone
stops me and says I still need or says I
they still need to get theirs. Why are
they getting it? Because they have to go
to a Catholic priest to get these ashes
put on their forehead. Another one
started my morning with ashes. They've
smudged a bit throughout the day and
sparked more than a few conversations.
So remember fasting,
it's all about not not doing it for
outward show, right? Praying in secret,
fasting in secret because it's about you
and God. It's not to parade around and
put on the internet and say, "Look at
me. I got ashes on my forehead for 40
days because the priest of Rome has
marked me. Think about that. The
Babylonian priest has marked my forehead
for 40 days before Easter, which is also
not a Christian holiday. When Jesus rose
from the dead, it was on a specific
date. And yet Easter never comes on the
same date, does it? It's always this
random Sunday in April. And sometimes
this doesn't even happen in April. Why
is this? It's because it has to do with
the equinox. This is all about sun
worship. It literally has nothing to do
with Jesus resurrection at all. But this
is what we've all been duped. We've all
been deceived by Satan who's going to
deceive the entire world. Do we believe
what the word of God says? Do we believe
that Satan is going to deceive the
entire world? That there's going to be a
push towards the beast system, a one
world ecumenical coexist system, or do
we not? That that's the question. Do we
believe the word of God and prophecy or
do we not? When me and Aubry look at
what's going on in this world, it is so
clear to us because God has given us
discernment and eyes to see, it's
nothing of myself. I was as blind as
they come. I used to be a Marilyn Manson
worshiping drunk
pthead.
Couldn't see anything.
But God knocked the scales off of my
eyes. And now I see clearly more than
ever before. And I've talked about it
with these Epstein files and everything
coming out. The whole structure is
collapsing because Satan is about to
take the throne. Satan is about to
manifest in this world and take the
throne because we can't put our trust in
men anymore and governments and
celebrities and none of these things
because of these files that are coming
out
and it is manufactured chaos so that
they can bring about order and Satan is
the god of this world and he's about to
manifest into this world and he's about
to sit on the throne
and it's coming sooner than we leave
sooner than we can even imagine.
Mario Lopez, he was in the show Saved by
the Bell and he's a fitness guy and he
said, "A powerful reminder to focus on
what really matters. Faith, family,
purpose." See, it all sounds good
because Satan is not a dummy.
Satan speaks in truth. He spoke to Eve
in the garden. Did not did God not say
you could eat of every tree of the
garden? Well, yeah, but if you can't eat
of this tree, that's a very important
piece of the sentence that was missing,
right? Satan speaks
in deception. A lot of truth and a
little bit of error. 99% truth is not
truth.
Here's Leela Rose. A lot of people look
up to her. I follow this lady on
Facebook. Had no idea that she would be
celebrating Lent. Uh she's a prolife
activist and that's why I started
following her. Lo and behold, here she
is promoting the ashes on her forehead.
Observational evidence suggests a
growing trend among some Protestants,
particularly evangelicals, to observe
Lent, a practice traditionally
associated with Catholic or Orthodox
traditions. So I asked is is this trend
growing among evangelicals? It's saying
yeah. However, recent data data
indicates that overall observ
observation remains low among
Protestants around 20 to 28% in some
studies. But I'm thinking that those
numbers are increasing because of all
the celebrities that are promoting this
growing interest. While historically
many Protestants did not observe Lent,
there is a noted albeit slow trend among
some to incorporate it in to incorporate
it for prayer, reflection, and fasting.
But why can somebody show me the
scripture? Show me the scripture that
says
40 days before Easter, which also isn't
in the Bible, put ashes on your
forehead, but have a priest put ashes on
your forehead and wear it for 40 days. I
need to see the verse.
This is what I was talking about. The
date of Easter is determined by
calculating the first Sunday after the
full moon that occurs on or after the
vernal equinox. This calculation is
called computalis
which is Latin for Easter computation.
So if Easter was truly the celebration
of the day that Christ rose from the
grave,
you would keep the date, right? You
don't celebrate your birth day in the
sense like, well, I was born on a
Monday, so in November, the first Monday
will be my birthday. No, the date that
you were born is the date that you keep,
right? The birth date. You would do the
same thing with celebrating the date
that Jesus rose from the tomb. You would
not it would not be this fluctuating
Sunday, right? Easter is a movable
feast. So it doesn't happen on the same
date from year to year. In the Gregorian
calendar, it is always observed on a
Sunday between March 22 and April 25.
That's a whole month between March and
April. It's more than a month that
Easter could fall on. Why? Because it's
not a celebration of the resurrection of
Christ, but it has to do with the sun
and the moon in the equinox. Easter can
be observed between April 4th and May
8th in the Eastern Orthodox Church.
Okay,
I hope this is making sense, guys. I
hope this doesn't sound like some crazy
rant, but it's actually clicking that
these things are not biblical at all and
they actually have origins in paganism.
And yet Christians are keeping it today.
And that's a problem. Revelation 13:3
and 4 says, "And I saw one of its heads
as it were wounded to death, and his
deadly wound was healed. And all the
world wondered after the beast, and they
worshiped the dragon, which gave power
unto the beast, and they worshiped the
beast, saying, "Who is like unto the
beast? Who is able to make war with him?
So, who is this beast?" I know I've
already said it, but I want you to be
able to study this out for yourself and
for you to know beyond a shadow of a
doubt that this isn't just some
conspiracy theory like, "Oh, some people
think the beast is Rome or the Vatican
or the papacy." You can actually do this
yourself. And if you want to if you want
to know that, go to our live tab, scroll
down until you see a video that says uh
the mark of the beast is not a
microchip. Watch that video. It'll walk
you through every step, every verse
about the antichrist, about the beast's
power, and you will know beyond a shadow
of a doubt who that beast is. But I'm
going to show you a couple of little
segments of that. Revelation 17:9 says,
and here's the mind. We just looked at a
one of the heads, right? One of the
heads was had a deadly wound. How many
heads did it have? Revelation 17:9 says,
"And here is the mind which has wisdom.
The seven heads are seven mountains or
seven hills on which the woman sits."
Now in symbolic prophecy, Bible symbols,
a woman is the church or and and the
church is the body of believers, right?
So if you have a harlot,
she's not the pure church, right? She's
a corrupt church because God always
called his people
going ah whoring. When his people were
going after strange gods and breaking
the commandments, he said, "You're going
a whoring." Because we're supposed to be
in a faithful relationship with Jesus
Christ. But when we stray from his
commandments and we go after strange
gods, then we are That's why
they call I want some strange, right?
You've heard that term strange. God said
you're going after strange gods and you
are going a whoring. So who is this
harlot that sits on the city of seven
hills? The city of seven hills is Rome.
This is the encyclopedia. Just type in
on Google, what is the city of seven
hills? It'll tell you Rome right there.
Then Revelation 17:4 says, "And the
mother of harlots," this is the same
corrupt church, "was arrayed in purple
and scarlet color and decked with gold
and precious stones and pearls and
having a golden cup in her hand full of
abominations." And who is it? You can go
to Google and type in purple scarlet
gold church. That's all you got to put.
purple scarlet gold church and you'll
get all these pictures of the Vatican
because this harlot church is everything
but biblical, everything but Christian.
This is an antichrist system where you
go to a man and confess your sins to a
man. You call him father and he tells
you how to forgive, how to get your sins
forgiven. He gives you some kind of
penance. say uh 20 Hail Marys, put some
money in the offering plate, and your
sins are forgiven. Nothing about that is
Christian, but yet it's the largest
Christian denomination in the world. So,
from a literal biblical perspective, Ash
Wednesday is not commanded in scripture.
Some researchers and occult theorists
argue
that the ritual of marking the forehead
with ashes is a continuation of the
weeping for tamuz mentioned in Ezekiel
8:14. When you look at Ezekiel 8:14, it
says, "Then he brought me to the door of
the gate of the Lord's house, which was
toward the north, and behold, there sat
women weeping for Tamuz." What is
happening in this scenario? When you
look into what the weeping of Tamuz is,
it was a 40-day ritual. And Tamuz was a
plus sign, a tea that they would put on
their foreheads. And where is it
happening? In the Lord's house, at the
gate of the Lord's house. And what's
happening today? We have Christians
sitting in in the church putting a tea
on their forehead for 40 days.
This is exactly where this came from.
The 40 days of weeping for Tamuz.
Symbolic connection in these views. The
ash cross or T represents the mystic
towel, the initial of Tamuz, a
Babylonian sun god. Now, I looked up
mystic towel, and it actually shows up
on Catholic websites, and you can get um
rosary beads with a mystic towel on it.
They literally call it this. This is the
Babylonian sun god. And isn't it amazing
that the Bible written so long ago has a
prophecy that points to Babylon in the
last days? That we know that Babylon was
conquered long ago. That vision that
Nebuchadnezzar had said that you are the
king of Babylon, but you're you are the
head of gold, but you will be conquered.
And Babylon got conquered by Meo,
Persia, Greece, and Rome. Those long
iron legs that go down to the feet of
part iron and part miry clay. This is a
merging of Rome, iron, and dirty clay,
which represents a dirty corrupt church
mingling together. a church state system
and that that system is going to be the
last one world religion that's going to
be pushed onto all the world by force. A
law to keep the things of the Babylon
church. Here we see those uh symbols of
the Babylonian sun god.
By participating in a ritual not
commanded by God, individuals
unwittingly align themselves with a
spirit of antichrist or a system of
mystery Babylon.
When you willfully
stand in line, ready to get your head
marked by a Babylonian priest.
This is consent. And see, before Satan
can take the throne, before Satan can
enter this world physically as an angel
of light doing lying signs and wonders
and miracles, and he will deceive the
entire world by means of those miracles.
The Bible says, in order for him to do
that, he has to have consent.
Satan can only do what God allows him to
do. He can only do or he can only go
where he's invited. And when we
participate in these pagan rituals, we
are opening the door for an invitation
for Satan to come into our lives. And
the whole world is is consenting to
these things. Whether it's keeping the
pagan holidays, whether it's putting
these ashes on your forehead, whether
it's reading occult books, watching
movies that um glamorize witchcraft like
Harry Potter and many, many others. We
are opening the door. When Christ
returns, all these things are going to
be used against us. Satan's going to
say, "Nope, they're mine. They
celebrated my holidays. They watched my
movies. They listened to my music.
They put the ashes on their foreheads.
They lined up for the Babylonian priests
to mark their foreheads."
Think about that through the lens of
revelation that there's going to be
people who have the seal of God in their
foreheads, which has to do with
obedience to God's commandments.
And there's going to be those who are
marked by the beast. And who is the
beast? Rome. Now, I'm not saying that
this physical mark is the mark of the
beast.
But I sure don't want to be marked
physically by Rome either. Deuteronomy
12:30 says, "Take heed to thyself that
thou be not snared by following them,
after that they be destroyed from before
thee, and that thou inquire not after
their gods, saying, How did these
nations serve their gods?" Even so, I
will do likewise."
God is talking to his people, and he
says, "Don't look at how the pagans
worship their gods and say, "Oh, we'll
do the same thing." That's exactly what
all these pagan holidays are doing. And
the next verse says, "Thou shalt not do
so unto the Lord thy God." Many people
will say, "Yes, I know this had pagan
origins, but I do it for Jesus. I do
these pagan rituals for him."
This verse is so clear.
Thou shalt not do so unto the Lord thy
God. For every abomination to the Lord,
which he hateth, have they done unto
their gods. For even their sons and
their daughters, they have burnt in the
fire to their gods. He's saying, "These
pagans that burn their own children, do
not do what they do. Don't look at their
rituals and traditions and say you're
going to do it to me. I hate what they
do."
That is strong language. Please take
this stuff,
think and contemplate on these things.
This is this is terrible.
For those following a strict biblical
path, that's what I want to do.
The warning in Jeremiah 10:2,
learn not the way of the heathen, is
often cited as a reason to reject these
man-made traditions. This is why I'm
here today telling you reject these
man-made traditions. Anything that's not
in the Bible, don't do it. Don't
participate in it. Jeremiah 10:2, "Thus
sayeth the Lord, learn not the way of
the heathen, and be not dismayed at the
signs of heaven, for the heathen are
dismayed at them."
Jesus talks about when in the end times
there's going to be many signs in the
heavens. There's going to be signs in
the heavens that men's hearts will fail
them for fear
and that Satan is going to be the one
behind it. That Satan's going to be
bringing fire down from heaven, doing
lying signs and wonders. And it says
that there's miracle working demons that
are going to deceive the entire world.
And many are going to depart from the
faith, giving heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of demons. Satan does not
have goat legs and horns. He doesn't
look like a scary monster. He's coming
as an angel of light doing miracles. And
if we don't understand prophecy, we're
going to fall for the deception. We're
going to fall for the strong delusion.
If we buy into our senses and we say, "I
see fire coming down. I see miracles
happening. This has to be Jesus. Look,
he even destroyed the new world order.
He destroyed all those people that were
in the Epstein files."
It's all a show. It's all a stage being
set to deceive you.
And Satan's main focus of attack is the
believers. He doesn't have to focus on
the lost. They're already lost. His
attack is on the believers. I think we
get confused as Christians. We think,
"Oh, no. You know, I go to a church
where the pastor talks about Jesus. He
has to be true or he wouldn't be able to
say Jesus." That's not true. If you
believe that wicked people can't say the
name of Jesus, then you're deceived
yourself. Look at the the cult of the
Mormonism. Look at the newagers who
channel Jesus and they say, "Yes, he's
one of my ascended masters.
Buddhist believe in Jesus. Islam
believes in Jesus." It doesn't matter.
Just because they say the name of Jesus,
that means nothing.
which Jesus you know Paul talked about
do they worship another Jesus are they
preaching another gospel Satan is not a
dummy he is a deceiver in Matthew 15 6-9
it says thus have ye made the
commandment of God of none effect by
your tradition
what is making the commandment of God of
none effect
tradition
rituals
things that are not in the Bible that
are being kept. Things that the heathens
do that now the Christians are doing. Ye
hypocrites.
Well, did Isaiah prophesy of you,
saying, "They draw near unto me with
their mouth and honorth me with their
lips, but their heart is far from me."
Why do you think he's saying that? You
can say these things with your lips. You
can say, "Oh, I love Jesus. I worship
Jesus." It says they draw near to him
with their lips and their mouth. But
what are they not doing? Obeying him. He
said, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." Right? So, keeping his
commandments equals love. And he says,
"Their hearts are far from me because
they only draw near to me with their
lips and their mouth,
but in vain they do worship me, teaching
for doctrines the commandments of men."
Do you see what it's saying there? That
you can worship Jesus in vain.
Your worship means nothing. If you're
keeping the commandments of men, you are
making the commandments of God of none
effect. by your tradition, by the
commandments of men, your worship is in
vain. That's written in red. That's
Jesus himself talking.
This is strong, guys. We are in the last
days. Is we are so done with just
playing church. Guys, we should be so
done with one foot in the world, one
foot in the church. Oh, come on, man. I
like this movie or whatever the video
games. Me. It's time to be ready for
Christ's return. But first, we got to be
ready for some major deception. I pray
daily.
Every single day, I pray for God to give
us discernment. Me and my wife give us
discernment so that we do not fall for
the deception's coming. It's terrifying.
Ash Wednesday, Lent, and Easter are
never mentioned in the Bible. For a
believer seeking to follow God's example
alone, adding man-made rituals can be
seen as a violation of Deuteronomy
12:32,
which says, "What things soever I
command you, observe to do it. Thou
shalt not add there to nor diminish from
it." So what's it saying? Don't add
traditions. Don't add rituals. Don't
keep the things that the pagans do and
the heathens do. He said, "Do do not
keep these things to me. I hate them.
Just do what I say. Just believe me,
your Lord. Why call me Lord and do not
the things that I say?" That's what
God's saying. You know, the the whole
history of the Bible and our world right
now is about us not obeying.
I mean, this is why so many of the of
God's people tripped up because they
were unequally yolked. They fell into
idol worship.
They fell into the traditions of what
people were doing at the time.
And every single time it led to
destruction, despair, chaos.
God saying, "Please, if you love me,
keep my commandments. I love you so much
and I have a perfect law of liberty. If
you follow and obey my commandments,
you will have life more abundantly. So,
I thought it was interesting that the
two guys that are really promoting this
thing are named Mark
and Roomie or the Mark of Rome.
I don't believe in coincidences anymore.
I just think it's really crazy that you
got two guys named Mark Roomie
and they're Catholic and they're pushing
this thing, the Mark of Rome.
So when I see this picture here, when I
see this image,
it just looks so sinister to me because
I know that this priest is a Babylonian
priest. I know he's in mystery Babylon
and he's marking the foreheads of people
who are lining up to be marked
willfully
gleefully
lining up to be marked by Babylon marked
by the beast of Rome. For a follower of
God's word alone, the mark on the
forehead is a significant red flag. The
Ash cross is a counterfeit seal of the
beast or mystery Babylon system designed
to trick believers into consenting to an
unholy alignment. God's command in
Jeremiah 10:2, "Learn not the way of the
heathen." And Deuteronomy 12:30 and 31
warning not to inquire how other nations
serve their gods to do the same for him
is the standard used to reject this
tradition as a deceptive man-made trap.
Do you hear that? If you are
participating in these man-made
traditions, you're setting yourself up.
There's no one to blame but yourself at
this point. That's why we need to read
the Bible, guys. That's why it's so
important to be in God's word because
when I first became a Christian in 2005,
I was not in God's word. And I was
looking up to people in my family, my
cousins and all these people who were
telling me, "Yeah, you can live like
this." Look, the Bible says this. The
Bible says, "Every green herb bearing
seed." The Bible says that Jesus turned
water into wine. Drink all you want. The
Bible says that King Solomon had a
thousand wives and concubines. It's okay
to fornicate. See, this is how Satan
speaks. And that's why it's so important
to be in God's word because we cannot
take scripture out of context and build
a whole belief system out of it because
it's not true.
And so when you see this thing about
lining up to be marked by a priest on
your foreheads, just know it's not in
the Bible. I challenge you. Look for it
in the Bible. You won't find it, but you
will see that it's a historical pagan
tradition and ritual, and no Christian
should be keeping it. Joshua 24:15 says,
"And if it seem evil unto you to serve
the Lord, choose you this day who you
will serve, whether the gods which your
fathers serve that were on the other
side of the flood, or the gods of the
Amorites in whose land ye dwell. But as
for me in my house, we will serve the
Lord." I pray that that is what you guys
are saying. That as for you in your
house, you'll serve the Lord. You'll
keep his commandments and his
commandments alone. You will not add to
and you will not diminish from. You will
not look at pagan traditions and say we
will do likewise unto the Lord because
he hates it. If this was eye openening
to you, if you've never heard this
before, or if you have, give it a thumbs
up. It really helps get this video out
into the algorithm. Share this with some
family and friends who might be on the
fence about this thing or might be
participating in this. Let them see
where this comes from. If you would like
to support this ministry, you can do so
by going to cantruth.org. We got Cash
App, Vinmozelle, PayPal. We even have
Patreon, and we got some cool
merchandise on our website, hoodies,
t-shirts, mugs, and we get about $5 per
every sale that um is sold on that shop.
We love you. We can't do this without
you guys. If you have been giving to
this ministry, thank you so so much.
It's because of you that we can even
exist. We are 100% donationbased
ministry. We do go around and speak. So,
if you would like to invite us to your
event, church, youth group, uh anywhere
your home to come speak, hit us up. Go
to our website under booking or email
us. We'd love to come meet you in person
and speak at your event. We love you
guys. We thank you. We will see you next
time on Can of Truth.